made up towns a fictional battle and a
botched secret code saving private ryan
might be a top-notch war movie but when
it comes to historical accuracy it's
further off than private ryan's post
keep watching for the film's worst
offenses
in any war movie you can expect plenty
of gunfire explosions and armored
vehicles while the weapons and vehicles
that appear in saving private ryan are
true to history director steven
spielberg embellished some of the uses
of these instruments for the film
for example the film frequently ignores
how hot weapon barrels become after
prolonged periods of repetitive firing
during the d-day invasion of the allies
the soldiers firing mg-42s from nazi gun
nests experienced the consequences of
this issue historically the german army
strictly forbade soldiers from firing
the mg-42 for too long instead preaching
the importance of firing in shorter
controlled bursts to avoid overheating
the barrels
if the machine guns were fired as
relentlessly as we see in the film the
barrels would have grown so hot that
they would have literally melted
rendering the guns useless in a brief
scene following the film's d-day
invasion the us department of war is
notified of the deaths of private ryan's
three brothers when the war department
colonel played by brian cranston learns
that mrs ryan will receive three
telegrams with the news that her sons
have been killed you can spot a map of
the world in the background looking
closely the map seems to be a mercator
projection maps of this style were
popular at the time and featured images
of some countries appearing slightly
larger than actuality during world war
ii this specific sort of map was not
used by the us military who instead
relied on a map representing a very
different layout of the world throughout
world war ii artist richard eads
harrison's projection of the world was
favored by the us military in his
depiction of the globe harrison placed
north america in the center of the map
splitting eurasia into two in doing so
harrison wanted to convey that the
entire war was centered around the
united states unsurprisingly this
approach to cartography appealed to us
government and military personnel at the
time
saving private ryan accurately depicts
all two real wartime atrocities
committed by both sides from americans
killing surrendering pows to nazis
brutally killing wounded american
soldiers while the movie justly presents
the nazi military as cold-blooded and
merciless there are some details about
the german army that the movie was not
so accurate about foremost among these
mistakes was the fact that many nazi
soldiers are shown to have shaped heads
such as the character of steamboat willy
while it might be common practice for
soldiers to keep their hair short today
that was not the case for german
soldiers at the time most nazis favored
a hairstyle known as the prussian crew
cut which featured shorter buzzed sides
with the hair on top of the head
remaining long like most hairstyles the
origins of the undercut are difficult to
trace but it's likely rooted in world
war one history when military barbers
had to quickly and uniformly cut dozens
of soldier's hair within a limited time
span simply shaving the back inside save
time this style haircut was popular in
both europe and america at the time and
can be seen displayed by civilians in
post-world war one tv shows like peaky
blinders and boardwalk empire
the haircuts of the german army were not
the only aesthetic mistake made in
saving private ryan the appearance of
american paratroopers uniforms also
diverged from historical accuracy in the
film paratroopers are seen wearing
either brown or black jump boots as part
of their uniform given the movie's
setting in 1944 every paratrooper should
be wearing brown jump boots standard
issue among troopers throughout that
entire decade only later in the 1950s
would black leather be used for
paratrooper-issued boots additionally
nearly every paratrooper that appears in
the film has a white spade mark on the
side of their helmet while it was common
for military units to have the distinct
insignia of their regiment on their
helmets the spade belonged to the 506th
infantry regiment soldiers belonging to
different regiments would have had
different insignia markings on their
helmets for example when matt damon
first appears as private ryan he stands
alongside corporal henderson a member of
the 501st infantry regiment 101st we're
coming out nevertheless henderson is
wearing the white ace of the 506th when
in reality his helmet should have had
the 501st traditional white diamond
during the final battle at rimmel
remaining american soldiers were
miraculously saved by the arrival of the
north american p-51 mustang fighter
plane
when the mustang passes overhead it has
a distinct checkered pattern on its
fuselage indicating that the plane
belongs to the 78th fighter group while
the 78th eventually flew p-51 mustangs
into battle like most american air force
units they flew the more commonly used
republic p-47 thunderbolts during the
events of this film the 78th officially
made the conversion to p-51s in december
1944 nearly half a year after the d-day
invasion
their tank buster served p-50 once
angel's on our shoulders despite private
ryan's observation the p-51s were known
for escorting heavy bombers on airborne
missions not combating german tanks
additionally the fighter is shown
dropping heavy ordnance on the advancing
germans even though it clearly lacks a
bomb rack or any additional rockets
attached to his wings or belly at the
end of the battle the fighter is shown
flying towards miller and the americans
flying this direction would be against
standard air force protocols american
fighters would never attack an enemy
from behind as that would mean dropping
ordinance towards friendly units on the
ground below putting them at significant
risk instead the planes would have flown
either from behind the american forces
or perpendicular to the bridge
unsurprisingly the opening sequence of
saving private ryan focuses nearly
entirely on american forces playing an
extensive role in the invasion of
normandy while it is true that the us
military played a vital role in
capturing omaha and utah beach the film
does not show the other allied forces
who assisted in those d-day beach
landings notably missing is the
appearance of british military forces
who had an active role in helping the
americans secure the nazi-occupied
beaches if you're talking about 1200
warships over 4 000 landing craft
12 000 aircraft in the opening moments
of the battle american soldiers are
transported to the beachhead via landing
crafts known as lcvps or higgins boats
lcvps were used by the us maltese and
french navies from 1942-1945
they were indeed used during the beach
landings at normandy but only in
subsequent assault waves in the first
wave the one captain miller and his
company are shown landing in british
landing craft assault vehicles also
known as lcas were used due to their
heavier bodies and added protection the
british buried american forces from
offshore naval vessels to the beaches
with the royal navy contributing
multiple transport ships to the assault
while saving private ryan does a great
job portraying the horrors of the d-day
invasion one of the dangers it depicts
wasn't nearly as much of a threat as the
film would lead you to believe shortly
after the us rangers launched their
first wave of assault on the
nazi-occupied beach many men could be
seen in the water fatigued from
seasickness and weighted down by their
equipment many real soldiers were unable
to reach the surface and sadly drown the
idea of a bullet piercing through the
water and killing men below the surface
as depicted in the film is a common
trick used in movies in real life when a
rifle caliber bullet is shot at a body
of water it loses all lethal momentum
and will sink harmlessly after its
initial impact with the water's surface
even high caliber bullets like the ones
used by the nazis at d-day are not
exempt from this physical law according
to science abc the faster the bullet is
traveling the slower it will go
underwater
the opening scene of save in private
ryan blew viewers away in 1998 and still
does today it drops viewers into the
middle of terrifying unending chaos and
death as soldiers scramble for their
lives while being showered by bullets
blood and bodies shown in lengthy
graphic details spielberg makes the
viewer uncomfortable while illustrating
the extreme acts of heroism and bravery
displayed by the allies in the face of
such overwhelming defenses as brutal as
the scene is the real-life omaha beach
landings were even worse for starters
the beach the american forces land on in
the film is fairly small in reality
there was a 200-yard distance between
the shoreline and the german defenses
in the film captain miller and his
company arrive as part of the first wave
of american forces on omaha beach almost
immediately pushing their way up the
beach toward the german lines in reality
the allies weren't able to advance up
that beach until the third landing group
arrived with the assault taking hours to
complete of course for the sake of
brevity it's understandable why
spielberg had to cut the landing down
the resulting 30 minutes still offers a
lengthy largely accurate depiction of
d-day when deliberating on whether to
send someone to find private ryan and
withdraw him from active service general
george c marshall played by harv
presnell recites a letter from abraham
lincoln the letter is written to a woman
named mrs bixby and informs her that all
five of her sons have died in battle
emboldened by lincoln's words marshall
decides to send miller in the remnants
of his company to find ryan and bring
him home
the boy's alive
we are gonna send somebody to find him
despite lincoln's letter being real its
contents were far from the truth
according to the atlantic president
lincoln had been fed false information
when he wrote the letter only two of
bixby's sons had been killed in the
civil war of the remaining three one was
captured by the confederates and later
traded back to the u.s army in a
prisoner exchange the final two
eventually deserted the union army while
the letter itself may be moving its
publication also stirred a lot of
controversy when it was originally sent
the contents of the letter were
publicized in the media and many of
lincoln's opponents viewed it as a
shallow attempt to appear sympathetic to
families who had lost loved ones to the
civil war rather than the gripping
condolence recited by marshall
several times in saving private ryan
american soldiers are heard using a
secret code to identify comrades in the
field
this was an authentic call sign used by
the us military during the d-day
invasion however the order in which it
is said was reversed in the film in
actuality the challenge sign was issued
by a soldier saying flash and the all
clear sign of a friendly ally was
indicated with thunder this may seem
like a minor mistake at first but its
basis in historical fact is an
interesting one the thus sound made by
the letters tnh does not exist in the
german language for this reason even if
a german soldier knew the correct
response he would have a difficult time
saying thunder without exposing his
accent additionally the codes and
responses used by the allies changed on
a daily basis soldiers were expected to
memorize both the code and designated
response phrase as well as which day
specific codes were scheduled to be used
while the first act of saving private
ryan is largely rooted in fact the
remainder of the film takes on a far
more dramatized presentation of world
war ii history in particular both the
town of ramel and the epic battle that
occurs there are completely fictional in
the film we learned that ryan and his
fellow paratroopers had received orders
to secure the bridges along the meritory
river while this was indeed a historical
objective of the us military following
the normandy invasion the task was
assigned to the 82nd airborne division
under operation boston ryan belonged to
the 101st airborne division and would
have had a different mission similarly
while the nazi division whom the
protagonist battle at the end of the
movie the second ss panzer division das
reich was an actual elite unit their
appearance in the film runs contrary to
their actual combat records before d-day
das reich held a strategic position in
southern france to quickly combat an
invasion force on either french coast
when the allies landed das reich
attempted to move by train towards
normandy only to find the railways
already sabotaged by french freedom
fighters the division was forced to
march north by foot taking weeks to
finally reach normandy when they did
arrive they ended up battling british
and canadian forces at khan in mid-july
not the american forces as shown in
saving private ryan
as unbelievable as it may seem the plot
of saving private ryan was based on an
actual incident that took place in world
war ii during the naval battle of
guadalcanal the uss juno was sunk by
japanese torpedoes killing nearly 700
men
five of these men were the sullivan
brothers who were on board this tragedy
was dramatized in the 1944 film the
fighting sullivans after the news of the
brothers deaths was publicized in the
u.s the military introduced the sole
survivor policy exempting the sole
surviving member of a family for
military service if all their siblings
had died in the line of duty in 1948.
however not officially a law at the time
the policy was cited as the reason why
u.s paratrooper fritz nyland was ordered
home in the middle of the normandy
invasion nylon the inspiration for
private ryan had three brothers who were
all reported kia this tragedy resulted
in nylon being ordered away from the
front he was stationed in england and
later shipped back to the united states
for the remainder of his time in service
similar to ryan nyland initially refused
to leave though was ultimately forced to
follow his superior's orders
incredibly fritz's older brother edward
had in fact survived his crash in burma
after being liberated from a japanese
pow camp edward joined pritz in the us
reuniting the family
people got it wrong because my dad did
come home check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]